eeuu y europa animan a ucrania a
recuperar crimea a 6 meses de la
invasión rusa washington anunció que
planea mantener sus tropas y anunció
ayudas adicionales por 3000 millones de
dólares para entrenar y equipar las
fuerzas ucranianas
en ese nivel debemos seguir elevando la
presión internacional sobre el
presidente putin y sus facilitadores
hasta que se respeten los derechos del
pueblo ucraniano y su país soberano
ucrania ha recibido una avalancha de
apoyo de la comunidad internacional
durante la cumbre virtual de crimea que
reunió a más de 60 países y
organizaciones internacionales para
mostrar su solidaridad con el país a los
190 días de la inversión
nunca reconoceremos la anexión de crimea
ni a ningún otro territorio ucraniano
por parte de rusia
y
ante el asalto de putin debemos
continuar brindando a nuestros amigos
ucranianos todo el apoyo militar
humanitario económico y diplomático que
necesitan hasta que rusia ponga fin a
esta horrible guerra
desde el 9 de agosto los ataques
ucranianos en crimea se han
intensificado el sábado la base de la
flota del mar negro de rusia fue atacada
con un dron se trata del segundo ataque
contra el estado mayor en crimea en
menos de un mes la península de crimea
fue anexado por rusia en 2014